first day back to school in this Swiss
town after nearly a two-month break and
there are mixed emotions classes are
only half full desks are regulation two
metres apart but still you can't be sure
spoken I think we've had a dose of
anxiety the pupils feel - as well
certain parents so it's difficult to get
back to the way it was but I think we
need to trust the authorities in
northern Italy where the European
outbreak really began they're taking
things even slower not even using a
school facility but a public gym as a
pilot scheme using a small group of six
to ten year olds to see if it's even
possible to socially distant small
children who are used to wanting to be
close together we have to find a way
that these children can play together
and we can go to work we've now been at
home for two months their grandfather
can't take care of them every day all
day they're still small they need to be
with other children they really need
this same story in France the return to
work to whatever sort of normality you
call this is leaving parents with hard
choices in Nice they were doing
everything they could to reassure
parents
we've done everything to make sure the
sanitary rules are respected we're going
to spend a lot of time washing our hands
and we have to be attentive to the
cleanups conducted in schools many
people desperately want their kids to
have some structure back in their lives
and they're being asked to leave the
house and work if they can these are
hard choices with uncertain science so
far I see I'm not that worried I've
explained to my daughter when needs to
be done in any case I had to go back to
working childcare five months without
school would have been difficult that's
what was scaring me inevitably there's a
lot of pushback in the UK nearly half a
million people have signed the petition
calling on parents to have a choice
about whether they have to send children
back potentially next month and so - in
France the mayor of nice couldn't agree
more
they set a bottom curly
it's important for families to have a
choice for all the families who wanted
their kids to go back to school I've
wanted it for them to do it in the best
possible conditions excited children
totally understandable anxious parents
equally so in the new normal it seems
everyone has to accept to some degree or
another that risk is part of life
Lawrence Lee al Jazeera